this is kind of video where he might
seem like I'm calling someone out just
no all right deep down I don't care
everyone just loves to create drama
Banda CEO he's talking about this guy or
this girl I don't I don't care okay I
just I don't this video is gonna be a
little different it's gonna be about
forced positivity let's let's just get
this out there to make it less awkward
okay I struggled with happiness I think
we all do and I don't think a lot of
people talk about it because there's no
in-between I think it's either you're
happy or you're depressed but what if
you're just fine they ask you how you
are and you say you're fine but you're
not really fine but you can't get into
it because they would never understand I
would say I'm an in-betweener you know
if someone asks hey papa how you doing
I'm fine all right I'm [ __ ] fine I'm
fine oh it's a little awkward is all
these honest videos I can't I can't I
mean okay put it this way there's times
where I feel really happy but at that
time I also know this is temporary and
I'm gonna go back to just fine
and there's times where I feel unhappy
and I know it's gonna go back to normal
that's just maybe that's just my
personal chemistry and how it works in
my brain I'm never constantly [ __ ]
happy because that would just be insane
I don't think anyone is constantly happy
died and if that's the case well I don't
I don't want to know you I don't think
that's a good thing
I don't think being happy all the time
is something desirable at all now if you
watch my older videos I might seem a lot
happier I might see a lot cheaper a lot
more positive and that's because I faked
it
I thought that for people to want to
watch my videos I would have to be happy
I would have to force positivity and I
think it's safe to say it worked I think
a lot of people on YouTube are drawn to
positivity and I think a lot of
youtubers are aware of this and that's
why they're forcing positivity on
YouTube
the thing that I realized after doing
YouTube for two years
forging positivity is [ __ ] exhausting
there were times where I'd recorded
myself playing video games absolutely
hating the game and just forcing that I
would enjoy it just pretending that I'm
having fun
pretending that this game that I'm
playing isn't actually a piece of [ __ ]
but people bought it you know people
love my old videos and I think people
still feel a lot of anger towards me
that I'm I what would happen was I would
play the game and be like yeah rich gay
and meaningless as I hit the stop
recording button I would just be in a
shitty mood you know because they I
didn't have fun at all and you might
think well it's his job to make videos
if he has to fake fake it he should just
do it because I want to see him play
happy wheels Oh to some extent I think
you're right but also what I realized
was that it's soul-crushing it's
extremely soul-crushing to do that to
keep that up for a longer time and I
realized if I'm gonna keep making videos
I'm just gonna have to be more honest
and say well this game was [ __ ] I'm not
going to play or at least make that the
entertainment the fact that the game was
[ __ ] which just no always work you know
bear simulator but it makes me happier
unless and it makes me hate myself less
so hey what can you what can you do
something that I've learned now after a
couple years I forced positivity is
something that I really hate seeing
these positive quotes I hate them I mean
I practically wrote a book on parodying
them and when I see other other people
other youtubers forcing positivity it's
so transparent to me what they're doing
it doesn't bother me that the fact that
people are doing it I think it's just
knowing why they're doing it they're
forcing positivity to get views on
YouTube and if you think about that
that's pretty [ __ ] up I think a lot of
teens are watching YouTube and I think
we all know what it's like to be a
teenager it's a tough period for [ __ ]
everyone and as a teenager you're drawn
to watching someone else being positive
as a fly to to light pretty much and I
know what you're thinking well if other
people are watching someone else being
positive whether it's fake or not if it
makes them happier well then there's no
harm in that
right no I think I don't get me wrong
though I think there's people on YouTube
that are genuinely just positive people
and there's nothing wrong with that but
kind of like when you make it part of
your merchandise it kind of changes
things doesn't it the smile more store
the fight for happiness because if
you're fat [ __ ] your happiness you know
this there's countless examples and like
I said I'm not trying to call anyone
else and just showing you an example I
think the reason why it bothers me so
much it'd be good it's because it's fake
it's just clearly fake you're forcing
positivity it's not real maybe like it's
it might be just a personal thing but I
value honesty more than then I don't
know happiness I guess I know I would
feel better thinking oh when I die I'm
gonna go to heaven and I'm gonna see
it's gonna be awesome
I'm gonna see all my dead pets feel that
I haven't seen my dead hamster and so
long feeling but I and I would feel
better knowing that I would feel better
not knowing that the universe is but
that wouldn't be honest it would make me
happier but it wouldn't be honest and I
think that's more important but seeing
youtubers force positivity
it doesn't just bother me for their
dishonesty it bothers me because they're
preying on people who are already weak
to get me use on YouTube I don't like
that you might be fine with it but I
think it's I think it's stupid I think
it's dumb and I think it's doing more
harm than good
a Harvard psychologist explains my
forcing positive thinking won't make you
happy hey how about that someone way
smarter than me said it then it has to
be true cuz I I know this video is going
to be met with with people critiquing me
saying what's wrong with being happy
PewDiePie
you got a problem it's not like this is
every [ __ ] movie ever is you got to
be happy that's
the end goal and if you're not happy
then [ __ ] your life okay let me just
read this one part a lot of our cultural
dialogue is fundamentally avoidant so
people will just say things like just be
suppository fine the tyranny of
positivity was what a friend of mine
called it she recently died of cancer
and what she meant was if being in
remission was just a matter of positive
thinking then all her friends in her
breast cancer support group would be
alive today
that's dark by sending out the message
that our thoughts are responsible for
creating our health well-being and
reality we are over valuing the power of
our thoughts while making people feel
culpable when something bad happens to
them they feel it is because they
weren't positive enough so forcing
positive thinking is not so great is it
are you have you opened your eyes yet we
must have some practice dealing with
though with the bad emotions when we're
caught off guard and forcing strongly on
happiness it's just gonna make us less
resilient is what they're saying the
last point I feel really strongly about
which is and it's the same for this
pardon I'm I know it made me really glad
that I read this from someone else for
the first time emotions like sadness
guilt grief and anger are beacons for
our values we don't get angry about
stuff we don't care about we don't feel
sad or guilty about stuff we don't care
about if we push these emotions away we
are choosing not to learn about
ourselves we're choosing to ignore our
values and what is important to us and
when we tell our self to think positive
and push negative or difficult emotions
aside it won't work it doesn't work it's
because it's fake I'm not telling you
don't go and be happy and I'm not gonna
pretend like I know what will make
anyone happy if you want to be happy and
if you're struggling with happiness just
know that you're not the only one it's
fine it's fine not being happy all the
[ __ ] time I don't think that's
reasonable I think it's wrong to think
that that's the case and I think all
these Hollywood movies all these stories
that are eviction it's not a real it's
not representative of reality and seeing
youtubers applying the same thing for
their personal gain I think it's kind of
gross
and I'm and I just wanted to give my two
cents on it do you agree with me or do
you disagree let me know in the comments
and I I don't know if this is the kind
of videos I'm really meant to be making
I'm I'm probably not qualified at all to
talk about this but it's a topic that I
care about don't get me wrong I feel
great I feel fantastic but I also feel
very happily unhappy a lot of times when
I feel bad that doesn't mean I feel bad
about feeling bad I feel great about
feeling not great what the [ __ ] is this
video about thank you for watching and
I'll see you in the next one
alright I just wanted to be clear that
this video is not aimed for people with
depression depression is a medical
psychological issue and this video is
just a generic view for your average
ideals around happiness please don't
don't get the wrong idea oh no I had
enough drama as it is please that's all
I wanted to say thank you guys for
watching and I think you'll enjoy this
one I've selected it just for you please
watch uhm but yeah pretty great I'm just
going to stay here until this video is
ten minutes